of course immigrants immigrants have
been coming to Europe since the 60s
at first when immigrants from Southern
European societies Italians Greeks
Spaniards they were easily incorporated
most of them went back to their
countries Turks were the first non
Europeans that came in a stay when I was
a student in in Australian German in the
late 60s I used to work in in factories
with Turkish immigrants and there were
no no Muslims in Germany there were all
Turks today are not Turks they're only
Muslims and so how both they are viewed
by Germans as Muslims nuts Turks and
they themselves with yourselves as
Muslims and means part of a global
Muslim Ummah not only as part of the
Turkish nation so this exemplifies how a
process of globalization has developed a
form of identity because we've always
how Turks can become Germans now the
question is can Muslims be European
because Europeans were secular there is
no the only growth of religion in Europe
is that of immigrant communities and of
course it's very different whether it is
mainly Turks in Germany which are the
majority of immigrants whether it's men
mainly North African or let's say from
the Maghreb in France other whether it
is basically from the previous British
Empire from all over from the Caribbean
to Africa to to to Southeast Asia and
South Asia in England which is much more
very type of immigration but everywhere
the real issue is Islam in Europe and
and of course the interesting question
is that secular Europe suddenly finds
themselves Christian not because they
are believers again but because their
cultural identity as long as they define
as Islam is non European it means that
then they cannot be like us because they
are not Christian or they are not
secular which is interesting because
there was a time when the say Turkey can
join us because it's secular Turkey
well cannot join us yet because they
have not yet the right the Constitution
the democratic practices they are not
developed but they are already secular
so they could join us
now the paradox is the more democratic
turkey becomes and the more it meets all
the conditions to join the European
Union reaches the Constitution they say
shoulder loss the more Islamic Muslim
their politics become so the more
democratic turkey turkey becomes the
more mass and now European oh no they
cannot join us but we we met all day you
told us you have to become like that
like that but we but you didn't have to
become Muslim why not
you had Christian Democratic parties
were not the Christian Democratic
parties the one that established the
European Union the Treaty of Rome was
established by Christian Democratic
parties and basically Benedictus by by
by the Pope I mean it was all all the
ruling parties in in five countries were
Christian Democratic and only in France
they were not rulers but they were the
leader French politicians of the
European Union were all Christian
Democrats the main figures but we have
forgotten is a story and of course we
are saying well you have to be either
Christian or secular you cannot be Islam
you cannot be Muslim mass and the mock
democracy is not possible I mean
Christian democracy was possible so
again it's a very our confused
categories within Europe and this very
interest in the bed do they have to
become like us and how like us meaning
they have to become Christian or secular
this is what I said about about Denmark
to become it's interesting that the most
secular European countries they are
becoming much more anti-immigrant then
the I mean Denmark in in Holland Holland
was the the kind of the model of
toleration
historically he tolerated the Jews were
expelled from Spain he tolerated the
Puritans expelled from England he
tolerated the libertine from the
Enlightenment an alien has to become
Dutch but now and they had pillars they
had Protestants Catholics in secular the
three pillars now the pillars have
disappeared they tried to establish a
Muslim pillar but the Muslim pillar only
works if their other
pillars now the dusk have become so
tolerant so liberal that they cannot
tolerate and tolerate those who are not
as liberal as tolerance their what means
that it's a very strange form of
toleration so no it's noise a serious
matter because really it's a quandary
that Europeans themselves realized we
thought we were secular we thought that
we had neutral secular states that could
accommodate diversity but we realize no
our states were not neutral of course
they were secular Christian and secular
eighteen Christian was almost the same
thing we were secular as Christians or
Christian High seculars whatever you
want to call it and of course nance
non-westerners always view it that
so-called secular this Christianity of
course because they realize the secular
is not this neutral space that somehow
como days but secularity is a very very
Christian phenomenon the way it has
developed there is a famous anecdote in
Northern Ireland you pass from a
Protestant to a Catholics own hands up
Protestant work or Cathal you know I'm
an atheist but which one a Catholic or
you know the same thing there's no such
thing as a secular is not the thing that
that that that remains when you get rid
of religion you are a Lutheran secular a
Catholic secular a Confucian secular
Hindu secular a Buddhist secular and
this to a certain extent